mr speaker does the prime minister
believe
that the current lobbying rules are fit
for purpose
uh mr speaker i i've joined
uh the writer honourable gentleman in
what he said about uh ian gibson and
uh i uh indeed share
the widespread concern about some of the
stuff that we're reading at the moment
mr speaker and i i know that the cabinet
secretary
shares my concern as well i do think it
is a
a good idea in principle that
uh top civil servants should be able to
engage with
uh with business and should have
experience of the private sector
when i look at the accounts i'm reading
today it's not clear that those
boundaries were have been properly
understood
and i've asked for a proper
independent review of the arrangements
that we have
uh to be conducted by uh nigel boardman
and he will be a reporting uh in june
and if he has any
representations he wishes to make on
that subject he should do to do so to mr
boardman mr speaker i know the prime
minister's launching
an inquiry that inquiry isn't even
looking at the lobbying rules
i'm not sure it's looking at very much
at all because
every day there's further evidence of
the sleaze that's now at the heart
of this conservative government let's
just
look you shake your heads let's just
look at the latest scandal
a wealthy businessman lex greensell was
hired
as a senior advisor to david cameron
when he was prime minister
we've all seen the business card after
he left office he
cameron became a paid lobbyist for lex
greensell
next thing we know cameron arranged
access for green sill
with cabinet ministers ministers and
senior officials
and he lobbied for taxpayers money on
behalf of green silk capital
we also know the chancellor pushed
officials we know the health secretary
met cameron and green sill we know that
senior officials
met green cell capital regularly
and now even more unbelievably
we know the government's former head of
procurement no less
became a green cell advisor while he was
still a civil servant
does the prime minister accept there's a
revolving door indeed
an open door between his conservative
government
and paid lobbyists
mr speaker this is a government and a
party that has been consistently
tough on uh lobbying and indeed we
introduce legislation
uh saying that there should be no
taxpayer-funded lobbying that quangos
should not be used to get involved
with lobbying uh we put in a register uh
for lobbyists
and those one party mr speaker actually
voted to repeal
the 2014 lobbying act and that was the
labour party in their historic uh 2019
election manifesto which he has yet to
repudiate
mr speaker they did say because they
thought it was unfair
and was restricting people's ability to
make representations uh to politicians i
think that's absurd will he now say
that it's absurd to repeal the 2014 uh
lobbying act
mr speaker he talks of the lobbying act
who was it who introduced that
legislation
david cameron who was it who voted for
the legislation
half the conservative front bench we
said it wouldn't be tough enough
and where did that legislation lead
two years later david cameron camping
out in a saudi desert with lex greensell
having a cup of tea
i rest my case in relation to that
legislation
let me try another very simple question
is the prime minister aware of any other
government official
any other government official who had
commercial links with greensville
and or any other lobbying role while
working in government
mr speaker all if he has any uh such
information
he should of course make it uh available
to uh mr boardman that's the point of
his
uh that's the point of his review uh
it's an independent review we're coming
to
me but by june i'll be glad we'll it
will be played in the
uh in the library of the of the house of
commons talk about lobbying mrs b
he's being advised uh by lord mandelson
of global council
limited uh perhaps in the interests of
full transparency so he can know
where he's coming from lord mandelson
could be encouraged uh to disclose his
other clients mr speaker
mr speaker i haven't heard a defense
that ridiculous since my last days in
the crown court
it's called the shoplifters defense
everyone else is nicking stuff so why
can't i
mr speaker it never worked i remind the
prime minister i not only prosecuted
shoplifters
i prosecuted mps over the mps expenses
scandal so i stand on my
record that line just isn't going to
wash with me
it was a former prime minister and i i
suspect now former lobbyist
who once said this isn't a minor issue
with minor consequences
government contracts potentially worth
hundreds of billions of pounds are at
stake
so can the prime minister now answer the
question the chance has been ducking for
weeks
how was it how was it that green sill
capital
a company employing david cameron got
the green light
to give hundreds of millions of pounds
of taxpayer-backed
loans
mr speaker whilst he was prosecuting mps
i was uh cutting crime in london by 23
and cutting the murder rate uh by 20 by
50 percent
and he you know he asked he asked about
uh uh
lobbying on behalf of of greensville uh
mr speaker you know
again i don't want i don't wish to
embarrass the right honorable gentleman
but he doesn't have far to look
it was though there was one person
asking for the green still bank uh to be
able to use the coronavirus business
interruption loan scheme and that was
the shadow defense secretary
mr speaker kirsten
it gets weaker and weaker it does take
me back to my defense
defense chasing the crown court just
ridiculous the
shadow the shadow defense secretary the
shadow it really wasn't a good point do
you think that's a good point you've got
real problems
um shadow shadow defense secretary
was speaking for his constituents and
for local jobs
that is a mill that is million miles
away
from being a paid lobbyist texting
friends
in government the prime minister says
this came to be an inquiry
but the person he's appointed worked for
the same law firm
which lobbied to loosen lobbying laws
you couldn't make it up what we need
what we need
is to overhaul the whole broken system
this
afternoon labour's motion calls for a
proper parliamentary inquiry into this
scandal
if the prime minister's so concerned
about this he should welcome the motion
after all to quote david cameron his old
school friend
sunlight is the best disinfectant so
will the prime minister vote
with labor today for a full transparent
independent inquiry
mr speaker i think he would have been
better off supporting the
uh lobbying act and the labour party
would have been uh better off not
campaigning to get rid of it it's a it
toughens up our
our laws and uh mr speaker i think that
his own
his own proposal is simply to have yet
again to have politicians
marking their own homework what the
country wants
that's all it is a committee of mps uh
to look at it
it won't do a blind bit of good that's
why we're having a proper
independent review if he has any
representations or allegations to make
uh about what has taken place he should
make them to the eminent
uh lawyer who's been asked to do it will
be reporting uh to us
uh by june yes mr speaker the prime
minister should be voting with us
not blocking a proper inquiry the green
seal scandal is just the tip of the
iceberg
dodgy contracts privileged access
jobs for their mates this is the return
of tory sleaze
mr speaker it's now so ingrained in this
conservative government
we don't need another conservative party
appointee
marking their own homework actually mr
speaker the more i
listen to the prime minister more i
think that ted hastings and ac 12 are
needed to get to the bottom of this one
mr speaker we know the prime minister
will not act against sleaze
but this house can so can i urge
all members of this house to come
together this afternoon
to back labour's motion and start to
clean up the sleaze and cronyism
that's at the heart of this conservative
government
prime minister mr speaker that's why
we're putting in an uh an independent
uh review that's why we have tougher
laws on our lobby a great shame
uh that labour opposed them uh mr
speaker yes we are getting on with
rooting out bent coppers mr speaker uh
we're also we're also appointing
and hiring thousands more police
officers
we're fighting crime we're fighting
crime on the streets of
uh of our cities uh whilst they oppose
the police and crime
bill which would have put in tougher
sentences for serious sexual
and violent defenders absolutely and
they then encouraged people who went out
and demonstrated
mr speaker to kill the bill we're
getting on with protecting the public
that's absolutely correct we're getting
on with protecting
the public of this country from crime of
all kinds
uh we're getting on with the job of
running this country of rolling out a
vaccination program
or or order